Have you heard of the SIGNATERA test personalized test that detects your cancer
circulating tumor, D&A, used to detect relapse, measure, treatment for efficacy and it's
covered by insurance for a medium to late-stage cancer, solid tumor cancers?
So if you could do a test like this that is going to measure a circulating tumor, D&A,
that is covered by insurance and by all means go ahead and do it. It is a blood test and it's not
going to be invasive. But if you have to pay out a pocket, you're spending $2,000 for it.
It's not giving you quantitative data that is going to be able to measure, you know, it's just
that whether it's going to go up or down, so there's positives and negatives to this test. But
that was the beauty of the IVG test. When we had that, it gave you more quantitative numbers so
that you could see if your cancer is getting worse or better. This will tell you if your cancer is
active but it doesn't tell you how active it doesn't give you that same data, but it could be helpful.
It's not a perfect test but you have to remember, no test is a perfect test. So
it's just it does, the last time I looked at it, maybe they changed their prices,
it was a couple of thousand dollars for the test. So if the insurance covers it, then that's great.
But if it's sure it doesn't cover it, then I think it's an expensive test compared to like a two-room